[Musique]
vous allez défilé gilles verdez mais
vous allez faire un truc c'est que vous
avez tourné autour donc 2,7 batte de
baseball comme ça pendant bien trente
secondes et ensuite vous allez devoir
aller donc donner des verts de cocktails
là-bas à mon ami voilà là bas rajoutez
pas gilles attention prenez le taper
vite vite le cadeau dont la démo à wade
et la nuit raquel ringard maman jean
michel maire
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bush
je ne fais pas les matins de ballet
macabre attention qui est numéro 1 la
table va le désigner
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
une aventure deyglun et
je voulais
[Applaudissements]
allez hop
habib le site il n'y a pas de la même
chose et s'est fait mal mais on s'en
fout mais là à 2
[Applaudissements]
environ 120 corps
ces messieurs nous allons fonctionner ce
n'est bien je vois la nouvelle et me
suis alors levé de sa mère juste peu
écrasée ne pas passer ça va sur vous
n'avez rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
valérie sauvage et saufs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va cueillir maintenant ah ouais je
sais qu'il y en a alors ouais ouais
c'est pokémon
allez vous dis merde
[Applaudissements]
vous devez boire vous devez bord
vraiment tout le match je n'ai jamais de
la vie
mais ça me regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible ça pas de balle et
surya bonaly
[Applaudissements]